the russians are at it again they're at
it again those
darn pesky russians you see there was a
minor story in the news it was this
little thing it's not even worth
rehashing
but it turns out that hunter biden was
getting payments from the ukrainians
to sell the influence of his father and
then he apparently introduced the
ukrainians
to his father and he also got lucrative
deals in china
and he might have actually been kicking
back that money to his father per
100 bites text messages but that look
okay that's sort of beside the point
this is a malicious scheme of russian
disinformation
and it's i mean it's you know they've
got pictures of biden and they've got
his text messages but it's probably it's
it's probably just really good photoshop
you know because it's obviously dis
disinformation none of it is true it's
the russians
it's the so it's khrushchev it's stalin
and nothing to see here folks right
except that the director of national
intelligence says actually
none of that is the case it's it's not
russian disinformation
actually it looks like all the emails
are legit
it's funny that uh some of the people
that complain the most about
uh intelligence being politicized are
the ones politicizing intelligence and
unfortunately in this case
uh it is adam schiff the chairman of the
house intelligence
committee who as you pointed out on
friday said that the intelligence
community believes
that hunter biden's laptop and the
emails on it are part of some russian
disinformation campaign let me be clear
the intelligence community doesn't
believe that because there's no
intelligence that supports that and we
have shared no intelligence with
chairman
schiff or any other member of congress
that hunter biden's laptop is part of
some russian disinformation campaign
it's simply not true and this is exactly
what i said i would stop
when i became the director of national
intelligence and that's people
using the intelligence community to
leverage some political narrative and in
this case
apparently chairmanship wants anything
against his preferred political
candidate
to be deemed as not real and is using
the intelligence community or attempting
to use the intelligence community
to say there's nothing to see here it's
not the russians it's not the
macedonians it's not click
farms it's not any of that the democrats
are corrupt the biden family is corrupt
and joe is literally running away when
he gets asked questions about it
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from kurdati who
said
kids at eight years old are
transgendering huh
when i was eight i still was curious
what sand tasted like yes that is true
this is this bizarre situation here
where the the left says that children
are capable
uh are of making life-changing
decisions decisions that they can never
come back from permanently changing
their body chemistry while at the same
time
saying for instance i don't know 18 year
old on a college campus can't make their
own personal decisions
why do we have an age of consent we have
an age of consent because we say
young people are not capable of making
decisions you know
certain decisions that could have
effects later on so we're saying that a
17 year old can't choose to have a
one-night stand but an eight-year-old
can choose to fundamentally change
their body chemistry and their sexual
appearance
doesn't make a whole lot of sense but
that is the way the
the woke revolution has unfolded
the only way to have tolerance and
openness and inclusion
is to trans the kids and that is pretty
gross stuff and that is child abuse
and the left unbelievably embraces it
all the way up to their presidential
candidate
joe biden who by the way has gotten
caught with his pants down
well i'm sorry a cnn analyst got caught
with his pants down but joe biden got
caught in a pretty crooked scheme
which we will get to because you know
joe
joe was always known for being like
really slick and really smooth
you know he's a smooth operator but this
time i don't know he didn't
not smooth enough you know what is
really smooth though buttercloth
buttercloth
is the world's smoothest softest most
comfortable dress shirt it's not stiff
and scratchy
like typical men's dress shirts i wore
my buttercloth
shirt to dinner about two nights ago
this thing is
unbelievable so they're all it's all
just using this incredibly soft fabric
that uses a special blend of 100 long
fiber cotton
and a unique manufacturing process it's
not some kind of weird material that's
super synthetic or something it's all
cotton but it's you've never felt
anything
this soft and then the shirt that i have
has these little mint particles in it
that when you put it on it cools you
down so you actually get like a little
chill up your spine it's unbelievable
i've never felt anything like it
the company was featured on abc's hit
show shark tank
in 2018 and these guys love the shirts
so much
that they invested quarter million
dollars and i'm glad they did because
now
they've grown into a big company and the
shirts are magnificent
buttercloth is offering our listeners
twenty percent off your first purchase
go to buttercloth.com knowles get twenty
percent off your first full price order
that is buttercloth.com slash
knowles know w l e s
democrats got caught in a pretty bad
scheme
actually even before we get to joe biden
running away from this
and and the cover-up from the media and
the cover-up from big tech
there's more news on the hunter biden
scandal so
you know these messages came out that
showed that hunter biden
introduced a russian energy executive or
a ukrainian energy executive rather
to his father while his dad was the
point man on ukraine and while his dad
was vice president
and it just looked like a pay-for-play
kind of corrupt scheme
so for a while you'll remember on this
show i said now the the emails appear to
be real but we don't know we're not
saying anything
now it looks pretty certain now it looks
pretty clear the biden campaign is not
denying the veracity of the emails
on the hard drives they have photos of
hunter biden so it's pretty pretty clear
that it was his
otherwise it was the greatest photoshop
job in the world and
beyond ukraine there's a another threat
in here
that shows hunter biden pursuing a very
lucrative energy deal
in china and possibly cutting his dad in
on the action
at possibly giving his dad a significant
portion
of his salary and uh fox is reporting
that this has been verified again it's
it's anonymous so you can't
say for sure but you've got
hunter biden using this phrase don't
he's he's
texting his kids he goes don't worry
unlike pops i won't make you give me
half your salary
well who's pops presumably if it's
hunter biden writing it pops
is his dad particularly in the context
of writing to
his son so now there's a possibility
that hunter biden is getting these
crooked deals by selling his dad's
influence overseas we're talking
millions and millions of dollars
and then he's cutting his dad in on on
half of that money
joe biden don't forget joe biden's never
had a job outside of government not
since the early 70s
and yet he's got really nice houses
really nice suits raises a lot of
questions
biden campaign not denying any of this
now you probably haven't heard all of
those details
why not because the mainstream media are
completely ignoring this story
shows you it shows you why the fake news
is the fake news it's not because
they get one story wrong or they
fabricate one story even
it's that they are not the news they
aren't news they are democrat operatives
and so
any reporter i don't care your political
your political preferences
any actual journalist if they got this
story they would be
hounding by them day in and day out they
would be crowing about this they would
be
on the news 24 7 but because the
news are actually just democratic
operatives they're perfectly willing to
let the story be suppressed and
president trump
called them out for it using very
specific language seems to be
to call biden a criminal why is that he
is a criminal he's a criminal
he got caught read his laptop and you
know who's a criminal you're a criminal
for not reporting it
you are a criminal for not reporting it
let me tell you something
joe biden is a criminal and he's been a
criminal for a long time
and you're a criminal in the media for
not reporting it
good luck everybody have a good time
have a good time
good luck everybody on that note trump
is
really a master of this kind of scene
because
it's because he's a tv star he knows
that a boring press conference in the
white house press room
is not going to do very well so you'll
notice he gives these press conferences
and they don't
always get the most play the he usually
gets a better play
when he's talking to reporters outside
of an airplane outside of a helicopter
on the white house lawn
because it's just more dramatic you're
more in the scene there's more going on
around him
and so he he uses this to pitch the
message biden's a criminal and so are
you
think about the question that the
reporter asks him the reporter doesn't
ask him anything
about an issue right it's not asking him
about the hunter biden emails
not asking about an issue that trump is
involved in
he's saying why are you calling joe
biden a criminal
and and now trump has to inform the
reporter
about this major news story that the new
york post broke
a week ago that hunter biden's emails
show
his crooked business dealings in ukraine
and china
how backwards the society are we living
in that the president of the united
states needs to fill in the reporter
on the news he says oh well i guess you
probably
you don't read the news or you do read
the news but you don't read the news in
the news
the biden family is crooked joe biden
was
not nearly as forthright with the press
as president trump is so he stopped by
an ice cream stand
on the campaign trail and there was some
press around and so
good old scranton show he decided to
make a a few fun nice little comments
about ice cream and he likes the
chocolate ice cream you know he doesn't
he prefers that to the vanilla ice cream
and then they ask him an actual question
like some reporter i guess snuck in
to this this grouping and said hey
what's going on with that whole ukraine
thing and china and all that
biden bolts
but i wanted to get what we call
and then he goes and you can't by the
way you can't just say this is an
example of gotcha journalism where
someone runs up while the well joe
biden's
just minding his own business and joe
biden keeps walking
joe biden stopped decided to talk to the
reporters about how he likes his ice
cream cones
really important issues probably the
most complex issue that joe biden can
handle at this point
and then a reporter again just kind of
snuck in secretly
and he goes hey what's going on with
that fbi thing with
and biden just the minute he gets to b
he doesn't even get the fbi out they
gives you
f hey what's with that fb bye see ya
and joe biden walks away puts his hand
up in a way that is not only
evading the question but incredibly
arrogant
not even running totally out of fear
running
with this pride saying look i know i
don't have to answer this how dare you
how dare you ask me it's my turn i'm
supposed to be president now
you don't you don't get to ask me those
tough questions bye see ya
that that kind of a situation
it just shows you how comfortable the
democrats have gotten
with the press carrying water for them
how disrespectful is that no
i'm not answering that tough question
call me when you want me to talk about
ice cream okay
the the biden campaign just does not
want to communicate
with the press it's very difficult to
communicate these days if you want to
communicate better by the way you should
use pure talk
usa okay if your carrier if your cell
plan
is with verizon att t-mobile you are
paying
way too much for the exact same coverage
that you would be getting right now with
pure talk
i know what you just heard me say is
you're paying too much for similar
coverage
that's not what i'm saying saying the
exact same coverage as one of those big
carriers
the average person who switches to pure
talk is using less than four gigs of
data per month
the big carriers though are charging you
for unlimited data
that's how pure talk saves the average
person over 400
per year on their wireless service
unlimited talks
talk talks talk text and two gigs of
data
all for just 20 a month i'm not joking
and by the way if you go over on your
data usage
they won't charge you for it i know it
sounds
insane but believe it or not when
companies are out there and they're not
just gouging you for no reason
and they're not charging you for data
you're not using you can save a lot of
money grab your mobile phone right now
dial pound 250 say michael knowles when
you do you will save 50
off your first month dial pound 250
say keyword michael knowles pure talk
simply smarter
wireless
so now joe biden is running away from
the questions
the few times that the hunter questions
even come up but don't forget this this
hunter issue
has been going on for a very long time i
mean we've known about this hunter issue
for
for years at this point and it's even
kind of cropped up into the press for
about a year a year and a half early on
reporters were bringing this up if for
no other reason then so that joe could
swat it down the trouble was joe biden
wasn't able to swat it down because the
scandal is obviously legitimate
and it's obviously stinks to high heaven
the the anger that that joe biden would
express
when he was asked this question shows
you everything
you need to know about whether or not it
is legit take a listen to a quick
little montage of joe occasionally
answering a question on hunter
your son's job how is that not a
conflict of interest
it's not a conflict of interest there's
been no indication of any conflict of
interest either from ukraine or anywhere
else
period i'm not going to i'm not going to
respond to that let's focus on the
problem
focus on this man what he's doing that
no
president has ever done
you said i set up my son to work in an
oil company
didn't know what you said i got your
word straight jack do you think it was
wrong for him
to take that position knowing that it
was
really because that company wanted
access to you well that's not true
you're saying things you do not know
what you're talking about
no one said that who said that what
so that's a trump ad and there at the
very end is that email from the
ukrainian
executive saying two hunters saying
thank you for inviting me to dc to meet
your dad
so that's who's saying it is the
ukrainian executive
even savannah guthrie right who's as far
left as they come
she's asking biden you know look this
doesn't look great for you
you know isn't it maybe just say it's
like sort of like a little improper
maybe and then we can just kind of
scoot this under the rug but obviously
hunter biden got the job because he was
selling your name
and joe couldn't even admit that he says
you don't know that
me i don't know maybe maybe he got the
job because
he goes to the same strip club as the
oil executive
maybe i don't know maybe they like the
same recreational
who knows who knows maybe hunter biden
is not qualified to do anything
okay he has no qualifications in
anything
he has one thing going for him in the
professional world which is that his
last name is biden
and that really only worked for him when
his dad was vp
or now that his dad could possibly
become the president and so
he sold that influence and who knows may
still be selling that influence
that is a major scandal we've heard so
much
from the left about how trump is
enriching himself in the presidency
but he's not right because then we also
heard about a month ago that trump is
losing a lot of money and his some of
his businesses are in debt
and he's lost a billion dollars while
he's been in the white house
and he doesn't take any money for the
job he gives away donates a salary
so he's not enriching himself in the
presidency you can always you can always
check this
when the left attacks trump for opposite
reasons he's enriching himself in the
presidency and he's going broke
and they say that at the same time but
nobody thinks joe biden's gone broke
nobody thinks joe biden's losing money
everyone realizes that joe biden's
worked in the government service
for 50 years and somehow he's gotten
real rich
doing it right he's caught with his
pants down much like
much like a certain cnn analyst
yesterday and writer for the new yorker
jeffrey toobin who was put onto
an indefinite leave because
he was on a conference call on a zoom
call and he was caught
getting a little frisky with himself
on on the zoom call now for
expert analysis of this this particular
action and this story
we turn now to woody allen hey don't
knock masturbation it sex with someone i
love
fair enough that's a good point i you
can't argue with that
and i guess that's what jeffrey toobin
was thinking too
jeffrey turban tuban is pretty left-wing
jeffrey toobin was pretty vicious during
the whole kavanaugh scandal
you know and and accusing kavanagh of
all sorts of
madness and particularly of a sexual
nature
and yet now jeffrey toobin gets caught
doing some weird creepy stuff
vice magazine reported this yesterday
that jeffrey toobin exposed himself to
members of the new yorker and wnyc radio
during a zoom call and this this
according to the story
the call was described as an election
simulation so now when i read that i
realized
this may have just been a huge
misunderstanding
because see it was supposed to be an
election
simulation and i don't know maybe
jeffrey didn't have his glasses on when
he was reading the instructions
all i know is the man was two letters
away from being the most meticulous
person
on that phone call but unfortunately got
a couple letters wrong in there
and now he is he is indefinitely
suspended this was on a call with jane
meyer masha gessen andrew marantz jelani
cobb evan osnos sue halpern and dexter
filkins all these kind of liberal
prominent journalist types
the reason i bring up this story is
actually two reasons
one trump's critics are worse than trump
this is i always you always hear this
from the left they say trump is awful
he's terrible he's vulgar he says mean
things he
dated porn star is he whatever you know
and i think okay well i guess all of
that's
fair enough but his critics are worse
trump is vulgar and he's made a lot of
money and whatever
uh joe biden is a crook who sold
influence
as was hillary by the way hillary was
the same thing hillary was also selling
influence through the clinton global
initiative
well uh tr you know trump has uh uh
says vulgar things joe biden says a lot
of vulgar things
well trump has made some mistakes in his
career joe biden's only made mistakes in
his career
well these i don't know these
republicans are blah blah blah anything
you can accuse these guys of
it's doubly true of his critics this is
drew clavin has this great point on
bigots which is
he he makes the observation that it's
not that bigots are necessarily wrong
about the people they're criticizing
it's just that they have no
self-awareness they don't
they're wrong about themselves you might
say oh that guy's awful he's terrible
[ __ ] maybe but what about you buddy
and so the the left does this here too
you know they can castigate
brett kavanaugh a milktoast lawyer
because i don't know he kissed a girl in
1982 maybe
meanwhile these guys are doing weird
creepy stuff on zoom calls but the
second point i want to make on the zoom
call is
we need to go back to work we need to we
need to take off the dumb masks
and we need to leave our stupid
apartments and we need to
stop purelling ourselves walking through
showers of purell every time we go
everywhere
and we need to be social again i'm not
making any kind of scientific point i'm
making a political point i'm making a
human point
we are not meant to be locked in pods
alone
for the rest of our lives we are human
beings are social animals
our defining characteristic is how
social we are in the fact that we have
speech
so we can communicate with each other
and if you put a mask on your face all
the time
and you block your your smile and you
block your mouth and you block your
voice
you are fundamentally crippling your
humanity
and i i don't care if it increases the
chances that you get the flu by the way
maybe it
maybe it does maybe it doesn't okay i'm
not i'm not delving into the scientific
question
i'm only making the political point here
people get weird and creepy when you
lock them alone for a long time
jeffrey toobin wouldn't have gotten
caught in this problem if he were in a
business meeting
in the boardroom of the new yorker
rather than on zoom i hope so or if he
did it would make an even funnier story
okay we have to do it i get the
you know the only good thing i can say
about the lockdowns
is that it has given people a little bit
more time to read but look it's very
hard to find time to read these days
and at thinker.org you don't necessarily
have to because they will summarize the
key ideas from new and noteworthy
nonfiction giving you access
to an entire library of great books in
bite-sized form read or listen to
hundreds of titles
in a matter of minutes from old classics
like dale carnegie's how to win friends
and influence people
to recent bestsellers like jordan
peterson's 12 rules for life
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across many categories from current
affairs politics
business education history relationships
they're great you'll even find titles
from ben shapiro find titles from matt
walsh
will you find my blank book on there i
don't know reasons to vote for democrats
you're gonna have to go check it out
i really like these guys they also by
the way sponsor my book club show over
at prageru
so they are so involved in getting
people
to read to challenge their
preconceptions to expand their horizons
and most importantly
to sound smart at cocktail parties go to
thinker t-h-i-n-k-r
dot org no e there's no time for that
you get a free trial download the app
today
let them know that you heard about them
on the michael knowles show that is
thinker.org
so tuban caught with his pants down i
don't want to knock him too much here i
don't want to
uh you know i don't want to attack him
it's very embarrassing i'm sure he's
having a very very bad day
uh and that's only like the 10th
creepiest thing that's going on at cnn
in
in the past few months however we we
need to reopen society and i don't want
to hear any stupid egghead doctors
telling me anything otherwise i don't
care what their opinion is because i'm
not making us
a scientific point i'm sure
from an epidemiological standpoint it's
it's better to lock ourselves and
wrap ourselves in saran wrap and sit in
our apartment all the time because then
you're really going to reduce your
exposure to germs but we're not going to
beat germs folks
we're not going to end germs on earth i
know i know the left is utopian
but that's that's taking it far even for
them there will be germs you will get
sick
10 of the world's population according
to the who's already gotten covet
20 of chicagoans according to one study
have gotten covet
or the disease has only been around for
nine months it we're going to get it
okay it's around it's going to be around
it's spreading
extremely fast according to the cdc by
the way
according to one survey of people that
the cdc was looking at
85 percent of the infected people were
wearing reported wearing their masks
always or often
just 3.9 reported wearing their masks
never okay and this by the way this
study that the left is so furious about
this study
that they keep trying to say that it's
not true never mind let's get it off the
cdc website
and and they're misrepresenting it so
they're saying it is not true that 85
percent of people who have had kovid
wore their masks all the time or or
they'll say
the the way they really try to twist it
is they'll say it is it is not true that
85 percent of people who have worn masks
got coveted
no that's no one's no one's saying that
i'm not saying that what i'm saying is
the survey is very clear of the people
that the cdc looked at 85 percent of the
infected people wore their masks always
or often
compared to just 3.9 of people who never
wore them that is
indisputable that that is right there on
the cdc website
which suggests to me we're not going
defeat germs by putting cloth over our
face forever okay it's just i don't know
i'm just reading
i defer to the science the left is not
deferring to the science though by the
way
you know they've been telling us listen
to the scientists listen to the experts
well only if the experts back up
their preconceived political notions
because you've got an expert on this at
the white house
dr scott atlas dr scott atlas
came out he tweeted that the masks maybe
don't work that well he tweets out
a an article from the american institute
for economic research
that showed that or that argued rather
that face masks should be restricted to
narrow circumstances such as
you're visiting an elderly sick person
uh in a controlled healthcare setting
you know like a hospital or a nursing
home or something like that
it also raised the question as to
whether or not widespread mass use may
lead to an increased spread
of the virus rather than less of a
spread of the virus the reason it raised
to this
is the same reason that an
epidemiologist at columbia raised the
prospect
to npr it's the same reason that dr
fauci actually
recommended not wearing masks early on
which is that people don't use them
correctly
so there's a world in which if you're
not using your mask correctly
you end up touching your face even more
you lower it or the masks are dirty
people don't wash them all the time
all perfectly obvious common sense
legitimate questions twitter censored
that didn't just censor the article
censored the white house medical expert
what happened to listening to the expert
oh only listen to the experts
if their recommendations help
democrats win an election that's what it
really means
andrew cuomo tweeted out andrew cuomo's
the worst that guy is the worst
he tweeted out a month or two ago he
said believe
science trust the science
he believes science right okay well what
does that mean i don't know that's some
creepy
creepy gnostic religious kind of stuff
but andrew cuomo doesn't believe the
science well first of all because he
handled coronavirus worse than any other
governor in the country
something like 30 of deaths from
coronavirus happened in new york on his
watch
and his policies sent send sick people
into nursing homes and killed a lot of
elderly new yorkers so he handled it
worse worse than anybody
if you're going to listen to science
definitely don't listen to
andrew cuomo telling you to listen to
science because andrew cuomo doesn't
know
nothing about science but on the one
hand he says listen to science and then
next he was asked
if he would take the vaccine after the
experts at the fda approved the vaccine
you know he said that he was not going
to test
trust the scientists well
first uh how confident am i uh
i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people
are that confident you're going to say
to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly
but trust this federal administration
and their health
administration that it's safe
and we're not 100 sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be
finally cuomo gets it thank you good i'm
glad i know that he's just saying this
because he's a hack and he doesn't want
people
to trust the trump administration but
i'm glad he's saying wait hold on
you're telling me that all these
eggheads and lab coats who have gotten
everything
about this virus wrong from the very
beginning now they're going to like
inject me with something nah i'm not
doing that man i don't know like maybe
i'll do it eventually but i'm
look i'm going to be a little bit
skeptical it's totally right to be
skeptical yeah you're right you're right
buddy
you're right i sure wish that you would
apply that standard evenly
because yeah i don't trust the science
you know the one thing i know about
scientific discoveries
like like in statistically 100 of cases
is they change over time
like every major every scientific
consensus that we've had at various
times in history
gets changed later as scientific
progress
develops as more scientific discoveries
are made trust
the science as their as they i think
intend to be using it
is a method of material inquiry
that obviously changes with
circumstances and is obviously prone
to error so the idea that i'm now going
to export
every decision that i would make about
my life to some egghead
at some particular time in history is
absolute madness but beyond that
the if these guys don't even understand
their own field of expertise
why would i have them answer questions
well outside their field of expertise
why would i have dr fauci tell me when
i ought to prioritize seeing my family
beyond avoiding germs and a certain
statistical risk from germs
why would fauci doesn't know anything
about that he's not a philosopher he's
not an ethicist
he's not a theologian he's not a
humanist he's not any of those things
he's an epidemiologist which is like
sort of a scientific discipline it's
like uh ish it's iffy it's a little bit
it's a it's a social scientific
discipline
i'm glad that cuomo is coming around
he's coming around in the worst way
possible
but i never want to hear again that the
republicans are undermining faith in
science that we're
prolonging the virus or anything like
that andy cuomo just came out and said
don't take the vaccine
so don't tell me anymore that trump is
endangering lives
ignoring the science i don't want to
hear it i don't want to hear it
and by the way it's not it's not just on
covid it's on the ballots too it's on
the vote as well
we're told there's no worries about the
vote oh yeah
yeah we've had uh mail-in voting now for
uh i don't know like a month and we're
we're moving voting way past election
day we're gonna have like weeks and
weeks of elections
but don't worry nothing could go wrong
that things are going wrong
things are going wrong in kentucky a
postal worker in kentucky
was just arrested actually for election
interference we will get to
that in a second but speaking of
expertise speaking of
real expertise you know small businesses
have taken a killing since march
many are still feeling the effects of
the lockdown jeremy boring our own god
king of the daily wire
has dealt with some serious problems at
this company which fortunately is still
around but there have been problems
going through covet 19.
actually there have even been problems
with the company when we were succeeding
that's just how businesses work
so we're excited to tell you that
tomorrow the daily wire guide king
jeremy boring is going to be presenting
alongside a team of world-renowned
business leaders at expert ownership
live
a two-day virtual conference about
leading through crisis
that features a lineup of speakers like
leadership author john maxwell
the founders of duck commander and
otterbox venom brothers many others
who can relate to what entrepreneurs and
leaders are going through right now so
visit
dot com knowles today get your ticket
for tomorrow that's 197 bucks
per ticket with an opportunity to buy a
second one for a friend
at 50 off go to expert ownership live
dot com slash knowles
buy one ticket for 197 bucks get a
second one for 50
off this conference is one of those
investments that your business will
thank you for
in the long run go to
expertownershiplive.com
to register for tomorrow's conference
also by the way thursday
we are going to be with you for the
presidential debate at backstage
check us out 8 45 p.m eastern
5 45 p.m pacific there will be an all
new episode
of backstage to watch the debate with us
get our immediate live reaction to this
major political event i'm sure it will
be very
controversial and crazy and even better
if you join daily wire now as an insider
or all access member you will get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all the debate coverage live
on our apple tv or roku apps head on
over dailywire.com
20 off with code debate when you sign up
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
trust the experts they told us trust the
system trust the process
well we can't can we because the experts
got kovid completely wrong from the
beginning don't forget they told us
they told us we had to lock down they
told us we shouldn't have locked down
they told us don't wear the masks they
told us wear the masks all the time then
they didn't wear the masks themselves
then we were told that any time anybody
contradicts that scientific success
consensus they're gonna be kicked off of
the internet so
so much for open inquiry and debate same
thing with the voting
same thing with the voting we're seeing
that now in kentucky a u.s postal
service worker
threw away over 100 absentee ballots
meant for the jeffersontown area of
jefferson county
kentucky federal agents from the postal
service office of inspector general
found
the ballots on thursday morning after
they received a tip
100 ballots we've seen ballots on the
side of the road in new york we've
caught election
irregularities in new jersey we've seen
some curious things in texas even
lots of issues here the experts are
going to tell you
that there has never been any problem
with mail-in voting
if you even suggest that there is going
to be fraud in this election
the social media will probably take your
post down
they'll say it's there's no evidence
that there has ever been fraud
there's no evidence well first of all
there is evidence in other
types of fraud but there's no evidence
that there's fraud in widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots because
we've never had them before
ever in the history of the country we
have never we've had absentee ballots
where you where an individual requests
the ballot and it comes to them
so there's a far less likely chance
that you're going to get ballots to
people who've been dead or to old pets
or to people who have moved people move
all the time
don't change their registration but in
this case because we know that the voter
registrations are out of date
you're just getting ballots they're just
being mailed out
we know that there have been ballot
harvesting schemes coast to coast
we know that there have been
irregularities we know that ballots have
gone missing
how many of these incidents like we're
seeing in kentucky have to happen
in pennsylvania or ohio or florida to
throw an election
how many people are going to vote twice
maybe not even intentionally just
they get a ballot they show up at the
polls how many people are going to vote
given a ballot that was for another
relative the other day i was walking
past a mailbox
ballot was just lying there right it was
like a kind of in an apartment building
and there was there were ballots on the
on the bench
anybody could take those ballots
we know that there's harvesting going on
at nursing homes
think about how razor thin the margins
have been on certain elections
and now you've got this obvious
vulnerability introduced into the system
what this would suggest to me is no
matter what happens
i think we're this thing is going to be
litigated up
you know maybe maybe all the way up to
the supreme court but certainly going to
be litigated
i don't care if trump wins 57 states i
mean trump's getting some pretty big
endorsements these days 50 cent came out
for him yesterday
great a great endorsement from fiddy he
said i don't even care if trump doesn't
like black people i'm not paying 62
percent tax rates
so something to that effect uh we'll
we'll get into the the full
the full video endorsement later on
maybe tomorrow in the show
but he's getting a huge number of
endorsements i see a lot of trump signs
out there i don't see a lot of biden
signs
but it doesn't matter because the the
vulnerabilities here
are are pretty great and we know that
democrats are pretty good
at stealing elections they're just very
talented at it
so this is a very dangerous sort of
situation and it's not going to be
resolved
on election night you know actually we
know it's not going to be resolved on
election night because john roberts
the putative conservative who's not
really a conservative he's on the court
he just ruled with the three liberal
justices
to put a hold on a lower court's order
that would permit pennsylvania ballots
to be counted even if they arrived three
days after the election now what does
that mean
right now there's an even number of
people on the court
there were nine then justice ginsburg
died now it's down to eight
so this question came up can ballots be
counted
three days after the election in
pennsylvania which is going to be
hotly contested that's a battleground
state
well the three conservative judges say
no you can't you have to get your ballot
in by the deadline if you're going to
mail it
the three liberals say nah you can get
man get mail out in wherever you want
and john roberts sides with the liberals
why don't we just impeach him already
on every consequential case john roberts
has
has failed us has sided with the
liberals has failed the constitution
why don't we we should impeach him
because this is going to be some
consequential stuff
it shows you this issue you know if
there were another liberal on the court
maybe roberts if there were two liberals
on the extra liberals on the court
maybe roberts would side with the
conservatives who knows but
you you notice this about the
conservative legal movement they always
seem to lose gracefully
they always say oh they write some great
dissents you know but they
often don't win these important cases
and john roberts just looking for an
excuse to preserve the institutional
integrity of the court the credibility
of the court how come he's not worried
about losing credibility among
conservatives
because i don't have a lot of faith in
the supreme court i have a lot of trust
in the court anymore
john roberts once again betraying
conservatives in a way that could cost a
presidential election
a lot of false promises we've gotten a
lot of false promises from
conservative judges from concert
quote-unquote conservative politicians
actually ufc fighter
jorge maz vidalin i don't know how to
pronounce his name i've never heard of
him i've never even watched ufc
but this guy i like him okay because
this guy
he clearly sees a political situation
very well
and he just came out very strongly and
endorsed trump
because he doesn't want to be suckered
anymore by false promises
i'm going to let you in on something the
democrats just think that they're
entitled to the latino vote
they think that we just have to hand it
over to them that's right
we sure as hell don't ashimi mo
i see me they gotta show us what they
can do for us
what they can do for our communities
we're not gonna buy the same wolf
tickets
and false promises that destroyed great
countries like venezuela and cuba
it's not going to happen you know what
else is not going to work for them
playing despacito on your cell phone to
pander to us
hell no
you got to give us some credit for
having heads on our shoulders
i'm going to wrap this up some words of
barack obama
he said elections have consequences that
is true
and those words have never been more
true than they are today
we either reelect president trump and
keep america great
amen
or we let joe biden destroy the greatest
country the world has ever seen
very strong endorsement his delivery is
terrific
it's just look this is obviously like a
pretty macho normal guy
you know he's not very woke i would
suspect in in
his comportment he goes it's like yeah
man look they've been lying to us
they pander to us they think we're a
bunch of idiots they take us for granted
on the basis of our race
usually and we're just not going to take
that anymore and it's a very matter of
fact and i that
i like the matter-of-fact approach to
trump because the left becomes very
hysterical like those gals that we were
playing on the show yesterday
but the right very matter of fact yeah
okay maybe you don't like this about
trump or that about trump but he's doing
a good job actually the reasoning
that jorge gives for why you should
support trump
beyond you know how offensive it is that
biden and the dems pander to people and
lie to people and have empty promises
he gives a great sports analogy that i
think is good reasoning we should all
keep in mind
i'm a professional athlete and i've been
one for most of my life so i've always
seen things through a sports lens
that makes donald trump our head coach
and before the global pandemic we were
winning super bowls
and when you're winning super bowls you
don't fire the coach
you don't doesn't matter if you don't
like the plays he runs the players he
puts on the field
or what he says on twitter you sure as
hell don't replace him for another coach
that's been in the business for 47 years
at every level
and never won a game
this is a great analogy and it gets to a
big difference between the left and the
right because
notice he didn't say here look trump's
our quarterback
look trump trump is like tom brady okay
and he's a winner and he's a winner
because that would suggest
that trump is doing all of these things
himself but we know trump isn't doing
all of these things himself
we know that the president actually has
relatively little direct power
much of his power is from the bully
pulpit much of his power is putting some
people in place
that then carry out these operations but
the president himself it's not like he's
sitting on his computer all day like
typing away emails and and you know uh
filing
like spreadsheets and things like that
he's not doing that his job
is one of inspiration to the people and
then
of appointment to get good people in
place that they can actually run this
massive government
he's not the quarterback he's the head
coach he's that and we're the players
and he's done a good job getting us all
to like
play very well and his appointees are
the players
and the pete and he's he's done a good
job there and this this analogy
of that to the head coach doesn't
reflect very well on joe biden
because joe biden's been in the game for
47 years and he hasn't went
won a single game he hasn't i
i really like that and it's very simple
unemotional
you don't need to get all worked up
about it and try to invent all these
crazy
theories about russia or whatever
nonsense it is
he's doing a good job by the way the
question
i think that the democrats were cheering
on in many ways the lockdowns and they
kept the lockdowns longer
than they should have kept them because
they wanted to
depress the economy bill moore told us
this and other leftists too but bill
moore in particular he said
yeah we should get a recession because a
recession will kick trump out and it's
better
to destroy people's financial lives and
get trump out than to have another four
years of trump i already said that was
pretty awful stuff but he
he admitted it at least and i think a
lot of leftists believe it
but i don't think people blame trump for
the pandemic they know the thing came
from china
they know that it was the leftists and
the eggheads
and the technocrats who were insisting
on keeping this thing shut
shut down over a virus that
has a 99 plus survival rate
they know that the big errors that
occurred in the treatment of the virus
occurred in democratic states like new
york
don't forget federal government made a
lot of masks made a lot of ventilators
did shut shut down travel from china
shut down travel from europe what did
andy cuomo do he sent all the sick
people to go live
in nursing homes so it just as a matter
of policy handling the virus obviously
the republicans did much better
than the democrats but i don't think
they blame trump for this kind of thing
i think they look at look at trump and
they say gosh you know this
this pandemic was pretty bad but things
were going well
before these lockdowns and maybe they
can go well again that's at least what
this ufc
champ seems to think that's what i think
a lot of other people are are thinking
too even if they won't say it to the
pollsters
the question is will all of these forces
the presidential
debate commission the media big tech
the bureaucrats the people counting the
ballots
will they be able to con collude
together to use a popular word will they
be able to collude
and overwhelm trump and that support for
trump
or will trump beat the establishment
again
a few weeks to find out we will get into
it the debate might have a big effect on
it so we'll see that on thursday
i'm michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there